David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 70, taken in Paris on August 23, 1946 at the Headquarters of the Joint Distribution Committee. The interviewee is Mr. Jacob Minski, thirty-nine, hm, who will speak in German.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Minski, wollen Sie mir noch einmal Ihren vollen Namen sagen, sagen Sie wo sind Sie geboren und wo hat Sie der Krieg gefunden?
Jacob Minski: Mein Name ist...
David Boder: Lauter, bitte.
Jacob Minski: Ja, Mein Name ist Jacob Minski...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Geboren am fünf und zwanzigsten (25.) November neun zehn hundert sieben (907) in Zürich.
David Boder: Oh, sind Sie Schweizer Untertaner, Herr Minski?
Jacob Minski: Nein, ich bin staatenlos. Mein Eltern sind aus Polen, sind allerdings schon sehr...seit ihrer frühesten Jugend von Polen fort und, hm,...die Staatsangehörigkeit so...nicht so geklärt haben..., also ich wurde im Waisenhaus in Hamburg erzogen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: So war ich die ganze Zeit meines Aufenthaltes in Deutschland; ich lebte also nahezu fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahre in Hamburg.
Jacob Minski: Ununterbrochen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Hatte...lebte mit einem Staatenlosen Pass und dadurch hatte ich auch Immigrationsschwierigkeiten. Sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich schon längst ausgewandert.
David Boder: Ja. Sagen Sie mir, sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Jacob Minski: Meine Eltern sind nicht mehr am Leben. Ich werde Ihnen kurz sagen...
David Boder: Ja, bitte.
Jacob Minski: . . . Ihnen das kurz erklären. Als wir in, hm,...im Oktober neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) bekam ich von der Gestapo per Einschreibebrief die Aufforderung mich an einem gewissen Tag in der Mohrweidenstrasse mit, hm, fünf und zwanzig (25) Pfund Gepäck einzufinden.
David Boder: Wo? An welcher...
Jacob Minski: in Hamburg, Mohrweidenstrasse.
David Boder: Ja. Das war neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941)?
Jacob Minski: Das war ein und vierzig (41), ja.
David Boder: Ja und der Krieg hat für Deutschland angefangen?
Jacob Minski: Neun und dreißig (39).
David Boder: Neun und dreißig (39).
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: Also drei (3) Jahre hat man Sie zufrieden gelassen?
Jacob Minski: Drei (3), zwei (2) Jahre konnten wir so verhältnismäßig..., das heißt wir trugen den Judenstern, wir waren gekennzeichnet, mussten in bestimmten Läden kaufen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und selbstverständlich durften wir keine Theater oder sonstige Lokale...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Das war nicht „selbstverständlich“—wir in Amerika wissen das nicht. Sie durften keine Theater und keine Kinos besuchen?
Jacob Minski: Keine Theater und keine Kinos und natürlich durch den Judenstern war es so gekennzeichnet. Das heißt: man durfte den Judenstern nicht verdecken durch eine Aktentasche oder so. Das war eine sehr strafbare Handlung. Man wurde...man wollte damit zum Ausdruck geben, dass, man „tarnen“ .. also,...es fiel unter das Gesetz der Tarnung und Tarnung war strafbar.
David Boder: Und was ist Tarnung?
Jacob Minski: Tarnung, das heißt...unter falscher...unter falscher Flagge wehen, sozusagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das heißt man verdeckt diesen Judenstern...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: .. (unverständlich—beide sprechen) ist Tarnung?
Jacob Minski: Tarnen, das ist, hm,...ich möchte fast sagen...das heißt in deutsch, hm, ein gewisser Schutz, eine Hülle, man kann...
David Boder: Camouflage.
Jacob Minski: Ja, kann man sagen, also eine Camouflage.
David Boder: Ja. Setzen Sie sich bequemer hin.
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: Nun.
Jacob Minski: Wir...
David Boder: Wenn Sie sehen, wenn das Licht aufgeht, wenn Sie sehen dass das Licht aufgeht, das heißt sie sprechen laut genug.
Jacob Minski: Aha.
David Boder: Wenn nicht, dann müssen Sie lauter sprechen.
Jacob Minski: Aha. Wir fuhren...von Hamburg fuhren wir.
David Boder: Ja also, sie waren dort versammelt.
Jacob Minski: Wir waren dort...wir wurden dort in einem großen Gebäude versammelt und zwar war das der erste Transport, der nach Lodz in Sch...nach Lodz...
David Boder: gehen musste.
Jacob Minski: . . . gehen musste.
David Boder: Warum nach Lodz? Wurden Sie als Pole betrachtet.
Jacob Minski: Das heißt...man kann nicht sagen, dass es nur ausschließlich Polen waren, es waren alle Nationalitäten, es waren auch Deutsche...
David Boder: Juden?
Jacob Minski: Deutsche Juden.
David Boder: Ja, und dann...
Jacob Minski: Dieser einzige Transport, der nach Lodz ging. War waren ungefähr zwölf hundert (1200) Juden unter Anführung des damaligen Transportleiters vom Auswanderungsamt.
David Boder: Ja. Was für Wagons hat man Ihnen gegeben?
Jacob Minski: Das waren...das waren sogar verhaeltnismaessig anständige Wagons. Das waren ausnahmsweise mal keine Viehwagons.
David Boder: Das waren dritte Klasse, diese Holz...
Jacob Minski: Dritte (3.), Vierte (4.)...so Holz...Holzwagen. Er hat damals zu denen gesagt, die dort versammelt waren...ironisch: „Ihr werdet in das gelobte Land jetzt fahren.“
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Na, als wir dann...hm, nach zwei (2) Tagen kamen wir in Lodz an.
David Boder: Ist der Zug schnell gefahren?
Jacob Minski: Nein, das war verhältnismäßig langsam, man kann das nicht sagen.
David Boder: Hat man Sie unterwegs gefüttert?
Jacob Minski: Wir bekamen von der jüdischen Gemeinde...wurden wir verpflegt, das heißt da bekamen wir so viel Proviant mit wahrscheinlich, hm,...ich weiß nicht, ob die jüdische Gemeinde informiert war, ob wir nach...ob es nach Lodz ging, jedenfalls gab man uns genügend Essen mit.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und als wir in Lodz ankamen, wurden wir dort in, hm, in einer Schule versammelt, das heißt die Leute in einer Schule beherbergt, das heißt, es war unter furchtbaren Verhältnissen.
David Boder: (unverständlich)
Jacob Minski: Wir konnten uns natürlich keinen Begriff machen, was das heißt in einem Lodzer Ghetto zu leben.
David Boder: Ach, Sie wurden nach’s Ghetto genommen.
Jacob Minski: Ins Ghetto, ja, ins Ghetto, ins Lodzer Ghetto.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Dort mussten wir natürlich unter den furchtbarsten Verhältnissen, ich möchte fast sagen, da waren die Verhältnisse fast noch schlimmer im Bezug auf die Hygiene und in hygienischer Hinsicht—als im Konzentrationslager.
David Boder: Also, wollen Sie mal weiter gehen.
Jacob Minski: Ich, hm,...
David Boder: Bitte warten Sie...(Lärm im Tonband)...nun?
Jacob Minski: Von diesem Transport...von diesem einzigen Transport, der in das Lodzer Ghetto ging, sind wissentlich höchstens drei (3) am Leben geblieben. Die Meisten sind entweder im Ghetto verhungert, sind an Typhus gestorben oder sind sofort ausgesiedelt worden.
David Boder: Was heißt ausgesiedelt?
Jacob Minski: Diese Leute, die untätig waren, die keine Beschäftigung angenommen haben, die meistens lebten unter der Vorstellung der Krieg würde sehr schnell zu Ende gehen und wozu sollten sie dann eine Beschäftigung annehmen und das war ihr Unglück. Ich weiß nicht, was mich bewogen hat, sofort eine Beschäftigung anzunehmen, das heißt man hat mich...
David Boder: Haben Sie denn eine Wahl gehabt?
Jacob Minski: Man konnte, man konnte, ja, es konnte jeder in seinem Fach...konnte er irgendwo, hm, eine Beschäftigung bekommen. Und das Lodzer Ghetto war—für die Deutschen—wie die Deutschen es behaupteten— ein Musterghetto.
David Boder: Oh!
Jacob Minski: Unter...unter Leitung, hm, des, hm, Juden Ältesten Chaim Rumkovski.
David Boder: Rumkovski?
Jacob Minski: Ja, der—ich möchte fast sagen ein ‚Ausbeuter’ war—zu Gunsten der Deutschen war. Wenn die Deutschen hundert Prozent (100%) forderten, so lieferte er hundert fünfzig Prozent (150 %). Also er war...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit hundert Prozent (100 %)?
Jacob Minski: Hundert prozentige (100%ige) Leistung—Arbeitsleistung/
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Er—natürlich lasse ich da...ist er.
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Idee, was ist aus dem Rumkovski gekommen? Wo ist er jetzt?
Jacob Minski: Rumkovski wurde in Auschwitz bei Ankunft—sofort mit seiner ganzen Familie verbrannt....
David Boder: Rumkovski wurde verbrannt.
Jacob Minski: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Man hat so Vieles von Rumkovski erzählt in Lodz...
Jacob Minski: Rumkovski war...war eigentlich wie ein König...wie ein König führte er sich auf...wenn er nach seiner Theorie, nach seiner Ansicht gehörte, gehörte jede Person...gehörte ihm. Alles was man besitzt und was man hat, gehört ihm.
David Boder: Ja. Nun (unverständlich) auf was für eine Spitze war das gestellt?
Jacob Minski: Die Deutschen.
David Boder: Die Deutschen.
Jacob Minski: Sie waren jedenfalls mit ihm sehr zufrieden, das heißt, dass er als Belohnung (lacht etwas) ins Krematorium ging—das ist eine Sache für sich...
David Boder: Das ist ein deutscher Dank.
Jacob Minski: Das ist der deutsche Dank.
David Boder: Aber warten Sie mal, das Sie nun auf Rumkovski gekommen sind—ich habe es schon von Anderen gehört. Haben Sie etwas von der Rede gehört, die er gehalten hat, wenn er die Mütter gebeten, hat die Kinder abzugeben?
Jacob Minski: Ja. Er...natürlich, wenn die Deutschen, zum Beispiel, von ihm ein oder zwei tausend (1 or 2000) Leute zum Arbeiten benötigten, so konnte er das nicht so erklären, wie es ihm die Deutschen sagten. So versuchte er auf Umwegen das zu hm,...
David Boder: Das zu bewegen.
Jacob Minski: . . . das zu bewegen, dass sich die Leute freiwillig zu Arbeit stellten unter dem Vorwand, sie sollen nach Deutschland fahren zum Arbeiten und wurden dann natürlich viel besser verpflegt sein...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und das bewog natürlich Viele, da die Meisten...da die Meisten sehr an Hunger litten...ich kann davon ein Liedchen singen...und sich freiwillig zu stellen.
Jacob Minski: Und dieses feiwillige Stellen, das war...so quasi...war der Tod.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . der Tod.
David Boder: Nun.
Jacob Minski: Wir...ich meldete mich als Feuerwehrmann—zur Feuerwehr. Und zwar ging ich von dem Standpunkt aus...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . das der Körper bei, hm,...wie soll ich sagen, bei großer Arbeitsleistung...
Jacob Minski: . . . oder besser gesagt, bei dem...hm, bei dem, bei der geringen Verpflegung, die wir bekamen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . möglichst wenig...
David Boder: Tun soll.
Jacob Minski: . . . möglichst wenig tun soll.
David Boder: Dass man Kraft sparen soll.
Jacob Minski: Ja, denn, Sie dürfen nicht vergessen, wir mussten zwölf (12) Stunden in der Fabrik arbeiten.
David Boder: Oh!
Jacob Minski: Zwölf (12) Stunden bei einer Wassersuppe und zwei hundert fünfzig (250) Gramm Brot.
David Boder: Was für eine Fabrik war das?
Jacob Minski: Das heißt, es gab alle möglichen Fabriken. Jeder...ich meine...(unverständlich—beide sprechen) es waren wirklich...sämtliche, hm, sämtliche, hm...
David Boder: Arbeitsmöglichkeiten.
Jacob Minski: Arbeitsmöglichkeiten. Ja, dass jeder nach seinen Fähigkeiten arbeitet...sagen wir, in einer Schuhfabrik oder...
David Boder: Und wohin sind die Schuhe gegangen?
Jacob Minski: Die Schuhe wurden natürlich an die Deutschen abgeliefert.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: Auf Bestellung.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Es waren schon Bestellungen, na ja,...gemacht und so...
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: . . . es wurde termingemäß und auch sachgemäß geliefert.
David Boder: Hat man was für die Arbeit gezahlt?
Jacob Minski: Das heißt, dafür wurde Proviant geliefert...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . man hat die Ware, das Rohmaterial geliefert ins Ghetto...
Jacob Minski: . . . und für die Arbeit wurde, hm, wurde eben Proviant geliefert.
David Boder: Ja, aber wenn Einer nicht gearbeitet hat, hat er dann auch zu essen bekommen?
Jacob Minski: Das heißt anfangs...anfangs war das noch nicht so schlimm. Später hat man die Leute, die nicht gearbeitet hat,...die nicht gearbeitet haben, hm, die nicht...eine gewisse Ration entzogen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das heißt, das war dann als die Aussiedlungszeit begann.
Jacob Minski: Ich meldete mich also, wie gesagt, zur Feuerwehr und, hm, dadurch hatte ich nur, hm, Außendienst zu versehen. Das heißt, ich hatte nur aufzupassen, dass es nicht brennt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Meine Kollegen, die mir mit zusammen gekommen waren, sind mehr oder weniger, wie schon gesagt, verhungert oder ausgesiedelt worden. Denn diese Leute, die keine Arbeit hatten, die waren ja ein unnützes..., hm,...
David Boder: Element.
Jacob Minski: . . . Element und die hat man nach kurzem Aufenthalt gleich nach Auschwitz, beziehungsweise in andere Konzentrationslager geschickt. Später...ungefähr, das war schon neunzehn hundert und, hm, vier und vierzig (1944)...
David Boder: Waren Sie so lange in Lodz?
Jacob Minski: Ja, ich war so lange in Lodz. Neunzehn hundert und vier und vierzig (1944) und zwar im Juli...im Juli vier und vierzig (44) erging auch an die Feuerwehr, wir waren schon die Letzten, hm, hm, der...
David Boder: Was heißt, sie waren die Letzten?
Jacob Minski: Es wurden alle sukzessive ausgesiedelt, man musste da Ghetto frei machen und man erzählte ihnen, der Amtsleiter Dieburg, der damals...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . hm, erzählte ihnen, dass es nach Deutschland zur Arbeit ginge und dass ebenfalls, dass wir die Möglichkeiten hätten doch besser verpflegt zu sein und...
David Boder: Und der Lageraufseher, was war sein Name?
Jacob Minski: Rumkovski?
David Boder: Was?
Jacob Minski: Nicht Rumkovski, Sie meinen...
David Boder: Ja, Rumkovski war schon weg?
Jacob Minski: Rumkovski war noch da bis zum letzten Augenblick. Ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jacob Minski: Das heißt Rumkovski für einen...einen Transport vor uns.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ich hatte eigentlich die Möglichkeit gehabt im Ghetto zu verbleiben, denn der Amtsleiter Dieburg sagte, dass verschiedene ledige, junge Menschen zum Räumen des Ghettos zurück bleiben sollten.
Jacob Minski: Ich weiß nicht, was mich bewog as Ghetto zu verlassen. Ich weiß es nicht...wahrscheinlich bewog mich die Rede des Herrn Dieburg, der, hm, speziell an die Feuerwehr das Wort ergriff. Ich hätte ebenso gut mit meinem Freund, mit dem ich zusammen wohnte, der auch Feuerwehrmann war im Ghetto verbleiben können, aber, hm (hustet) ich entschloss mich doch dann dem Transport anzuschließen, der angeblich nach Deutschland zum Arbeiten fuhr. Wir wurden in Viehwagons...in plombierten Viehwagons verladen, das heißt zu achtzig.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Durchschnittlich zu achtzig (80)...(beide sprechen)...
David Boder: Männer und Frauen zusammen?
Jacob Minski: Männer, Frauen und Kinder. Ja, in diesem Augenblick, muss ich fast sagen, bereute ich, dass ich mich dazu entschlossen hatte. Wenn ich auch nicht genau wusste, dass es in ein Konzentrationslager ging, so hatte ich eine merkwürdige Vorstellung, denn wenn man zum Arbeiten fährt—unter solchen Bedingungen, wie es uns da erzählt wurde, da fand ich es eigentlich ich merkwürdig, dass man uns in Viehwagons plombiert, ohne die Möglichkeit, hm, hm, sagen wir mal, austreten zu können...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und kein Licht, gar nichts. Zum...glücklicherweise hatte einer unter uns einen Bohrer...
Jacob Minski: . . . so dass er kleines Loch in den Fußboden bohrte, hm,...bohrte und...
David Boder: In den Boden?
Jacob Minski: . . . in den Boden, um seine Not dort verrichten zu können. Wir waren also zwei (2) Tage unterwegs ohne die geringste Möglichkeit zu, hm, uns bewegen zu können. Sie können sich vorstellen in welchem Zustand wir dann in, hm,...
David Boder: Ankamen.
Jacob Minski: . . . in Auschwitz ankamen.
David Boder: Also warten Sie mal. Ich will etwas mehr Detail haben, mehr Einzelheiten haben über diese Reise. Also wie viele Leute ungefähr, schätzen Sie waren...
Jacob Minski: Wir waren, wir waren achtzig (80) Leute.
David Boder: Woher wissen Sie die Zahl?
Jacob Minski: Also wir wussten ja, dass ungefähr achtzig (80) pro Wagon sind, denn wir sahen ja vor uns die Leute, die von der SS oder von der, hm, von der SS möchte ich fast sagen, mit Knüppeln, nicht wahr, reingetrieben wurden. Und soweit eben nun dieser Wagon, sagen wir mal, Leute fassen konnte, so viel wurde gefahren, ich meine, in manchen Wagons konnten es vielleicht sogar weniger als achtzig (80) sein, mache haben mehr gehabt...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . aber man kann durchschnittlich achtzig (80) Leute rechnen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun und da waren Männer, Frauen und...(beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: Männer, Frauen und Kinder, nicht wahr, mit ihrem Gepäck natürlich...
David Boder: Sie konnten Gepäck mitnehmen?
Jacob Minski: Ja, sie konnten Gepäck mitnehmen, das hat man ihnen nicht verwehrt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: So viel eben einer tragen konnte.
Jacob Minski: Natürlich die Leute sagten sich, wenn sie nach Deutschland zum Arbeiten gehen, dann nehmen sie natürlich auch Arbeitskleider...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und jeder nahm sein Hab und Gut, eben alles was er besaß, nahm er mit.
David Boder: Und dann hat man sie eben in Wagons verladen. Waren da Fenster?
Jacob Minski: Es waren keine Fenster. Es waren...mitunter waren so kleine Risse hier und da...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: in den Wagons...
David Boder: Nun...wie...wie haben Sie Ihre, hm, Ihre, hm, Ihre Bedürfnisse befriedigt?
Jacob Minski: Eben! Ich sagte Ihnen doch das. Glücklicherweise hat dieser Eine ein Loch in den Fußboden gebohrt, sonst hätten wir ja nicht einmal unsere Not verrichten können...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Wie gross war das Loch?
Jacob Minski: . . . und Sie können sich vorstellen...das Loch war, hm, hatte einen Durchmesser vielleicht von zehn (10) Zentimetern.
David Boder: Man konnte auch den Stuhlgang durchpressen?
Jacob Minski: Vielleicht...da geht man (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: Und was haben die Frauen getan?
Jacob Minski: Sie können sich vorstellen, wie Leute...bei der Nervosität, die dann auch herrscht, dass jeder das Bedürfnis hat, natürlich, hm, auch mehr zu müssen, nicht wahr...
David Boder: Ja...und...
Jacob Minski: Hm, das wirkte sich natürlich katastrophal aus. Wir kamen unter den furcht...den furchtbarsten Bedingungen...kamen wir in Auschwitz an.
David Boder: Können Sie mir das Betragen einzelner Passagiere beschreiben. Gewisser Passagiere? Sagen wir mal, waren da...
Jacob Minski: Anfangs...anfangs waren wir, sagen wir mal, gar nicht so schlechten Mutes. Wir dachten vielleicht...
David Boder: Sind sie gesessen oder gestanden?
Jacob Minski: Wir sind teils gesessen, teils gestanden. Alles war so eng, dass wir uns nicht rühren konnten, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Wir konnten uns nicht sehr, sehr bewegen.
Jacob Minski: Nun die Stimmung war anfangs, wie schon gesagt, hm, wir versuchten diese Stimmung...hm,...na, wie soll ich sagen...
David Boder: Sich...Mut zu behalten?
Jacob Minski: Ja, vielleicht, den Mut zu behalten, na.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und nachher...ja, wir haben uns unterhalten, und Gutenteils waren wir guten Mutes. Manche versuchten sogar Witze zu machen...um eben über die Situation hin weg zu kommen.
David Boder: Sich hinweg zu täuschen.
Jacob Minski: Erst als die Reise kein Ende nahm, kamen doch gewisse Bedenken bei den Einzelnen auf...
David Boder: Hat man ihnen was zu essen gegeben in den Wagen?
Jacob Minski: Nur das was wir mitgenommen haben.
David Boder: Was haben Sie mit sich gehabt? Hat das Wasser gereicht?
Jacob Minski: Nein, das heißt Wasser konnte man nur...bevor der Wagon plombiert wurde, hatte man Wasser gereicht.
David Boder: Was haben sie mit gehabt?
Jacob Minski: Nur Rüben, man versuchte den Leuten...und nur wer einem den Becher eben entgegen streckte
David Boder: Dem hat man was hinein gegeben.
Jacob Minski: Dem hat man was gegeben, das heißt auch nicht immer, nicht immer waren die SS damit einverstanden.
David Boder: Ja. Waren die SS in Lodz?
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: Oder waren es Polen oder Ukrainer?
Jacob Minski: Ich kann as nicht genau beurteilen. Es waren, hm,...es waren meistens Deutsche, oder, wie sagt man...
David Boder: Ja?
Jacob Minski: . . . oder...Volksdeutsche, nicht?
David Boder: Ja, Volksdeutsche
Jacob Minski: Ja, Volksdeutsche. Ja, die Ankunft in Auschwitz war auch ein bisschen merkwürdig. Jedenfalls als der Wagon aufgemacht wurde, sahen wir zum ersten Mal Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Häftlinge in gestreiften Anzügen. Der Eine sprach mich an und bat mich, ihm meine Armbanduhr zu geben mit der, hm, Bemerkung, ich würde so wie so jetzt zum Petrus gehen.
David Boder: Was heißt zum Petrus gehen?
Jacob Minski: Zum Petrus heißt zum lieben Gott gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das heißt...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: War das ein jüdischer Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Ich konnte das nicht so beurteilen im Moment...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . bei der Nervosität kann man das nicht so...
Jacob Minski: Was das bedeuten soll, das habe ich erst später erfahren.
David Boder: Hat man denn in Lodz nicht gewusst, was man in diesen Lagern tut?
Jacob Minski: Ich...wir sind...wir waren so eigentlich von der Außenwelt abgeschlossen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Dadurch haben wir eben sehr wenig gewusst auch...wir waren nicht...,.
David Boder: Nun, er hat sie um Ihre Uhr gebeten. Was haben Sie gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Daraufhin war ich...es fiel mir natürlich nicht im Traum ein, die Uhr herzugeben, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Ist das die selbe Uhr?
Jacob Minski: Nein, das ist nicht die Selbe, diese habe ich hier erstanden.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Hm, also...ja, darauf hin sollten wir aus dem Wagon raus und alles Gepäck liegen lassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Wir sollen uns ausserdem noch zu fünft—in fünfer (5) Reihen—hin stellen und ein Uniform...ein Uniformierter, der sich als der Lagerarzt später herausstellte, und der hat lediglich durch Zeichen links und rechts, hm, gezeigt wohin wir zu gehen hätten. Dass das, hm, nach links gehen—ich meine von mir aus gesehen—ist ins Lager gegangen und rechts gegangene Leute gleich in den Ofen...in das Krematorium gingen—das konnten wir natürlich nicht...das wussten wir, Gott sei Dank, nicht.
David Boder: Aber dann haben Sie...(beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: Ich habe nur bemerkt...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . das habe ich nur bemerkt, wie ein Häftling, der an der...diese sogenannten Kanadier...
Jacob Minski: . . . man nannte sie Kanadier, sie waren Bahnarbeiter, ich weiß nicht warum sie...
David Boder: Warum man sie Kanadier nennt?
Jacob Minski: Ja. Sie wurden Kanadier genannt, es gibt auch wirklich keine Erklärung für diesen Namen. Ich bemerkte jedenfalls, wie einer, ein Häftling, der an der Bahn arbeitet, von einer jungen Frau das Kind...ihr das Kind entriss, um es einer älteren Frau zuzuschieben.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das hatte, das hatte folgende Bewandtnis: eine alte, eine alte Person, eine ältere Person musste auf jeden Fall ins Krematorium gehen...
Jacob Minski: . . . während junge, ein jüngere Person—alleine, unbegleitet von Kindern...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . die Aussicht hatte ins Lager hinein zu gehen.
David Boder: Und da hat er das Kind weggenommen.
Jacob Minski: Natürlich, das konnte er nur machen, vielleicht in einem Augenblock, wo der Lagerarzt das nicht bemerkt hat.
David Boder: Hat sie das gewusst?
Jacob Minski: Sie wusste natürlich nicht, was das bedeuten sollte. Er nahm ihr das Kind aus der Hand und schub es einer älteren Frau zu.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Da sie später so...
David Boder: Sowieso.
Jacob Minski: . . . verbrannt wird...sowieso verbrannt wird.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Das wurden wir natürlich erst später gewahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Der Einmarsch in das Lager war auch nicht sehr, war auch nicht besonders erfreulich, das heißt...
David Boder: Also warten Sie ein bisserl...wir müssen die Einzelheiten haben. Nun?
Jacob Minski: Wir marschierten in das Lager hinein, das heißt die ganze Feuerwehr, ausnahmsweise deren, die vor uns fuhren.
David Boder: Die Lodzer Feuerwehr?
Jacob Minski: Die Lodzer Feuerwehr, ich gehörte ja zur Lodzer Feuerwehr, die jüdische Lodzer Feuerwehr.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Wenn ich hörte von den einzelnen Transporten, wo auch die jüdische Polizei dabei war, wir hatten ja auch eine jüdische Polizei...
Jacob Minski: . . . dass ein großer Teil von ihnen verbrannt wurde.
David Boder: Warum?
Jacob Minski: Sie sollten sich nicht anständig der Bevölkerung gegenüber gezeigt haben...
David Boder: Der Jüdischen?
Jacob Minski: Der jüdischen Bevölkerung natürlich.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Und da die Polizei einen sehr schlechten Namen hatte bei der Bevölkerung und viele Häftlinge schon bereits im Konzentrationslager waren, die ja auch schon früher im Lodzer Ghetto waren, also die vor uns gekommen waren, hatten die Aufseher von dieser, von dieser Tatsache, hm, verständigt und die, für die war es ja gar kein Unterschied, wen sie da verbrannten, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und so...
David Boder: Und die Aufseher, waren die Aufseher auch jüdische Häftlinge?
Jacob Minski: Es waren nicht nur...es gab unter ihnen auch, sagen wir mal, auf Grund ihrer, hm, langjährigen Inhaftierung...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: eine gewisse, hm,...
David Boder: Solidarität mit anderen Häftlingen.
Jacob Minski: Da manche auch eine Sonderstellung einnahmen—so als...als Capo...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . oder so.
David Boder: Ich möchte sehen, ob ich das grad verstehe. Die Häftlinge, die etwas gegen jüdischen Polizisten hatten...die jüdischen Häftlinge...
Jacob Minski: Ja, ja.
David Boder: . . . haben dann...
Jacob Minski: . . . die haben dann, als diese ankamen...
David Boder: . . . später, als diese kamen...
Jacob Minski: . . . das bei diesen so arrangiert, dass man diese gleich in den Ofen, hm,...
David Boder: . . . in den Ofen geschoben hat. Nun...
Jacob Minski: Wir wurden dann auf einem Platz versammelt und man ließ uns, alles was wir in den Taschen hätten auf den Fußboden werfen, das heißt Uhren, Gold und so weiter...also alles (unverständlich), denn das Gepäck mussten wir ja sowieso dort lassen.
David Boder: Wer hat das...
Jacob Minski: Also sagen wir, da hätte jemand eine Uhr oder eine, hm, eine Armbanduhr, einen Ring...
David Boder: Ja?
Jacob Minski: . . . oder sonst irgend etwas was einen Wert präsentiert, so musste er es auf den Fußboden hinlegen.
David Boder: Sogar einen Trauring?
Jacob Minski: Ganz egal. Jeden Gegenstand. Er durfte nichts behalten.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Wir wurden dann...nachdem dieses geschehen war, mussten wir uns entkleiden, die Kleider mussten wir draußen...
David Boder: Das war auf der Strasse?
Jacob Minski: . . . das war, nein das war auf einem freien Platz, auf einem freien Platz, das heißt es hatte einen Zaun und war (beide sprechen)...
David Boder: . . . aber draußen unter dem klaren Himmel...
Jacob Minski: Ja, unter klarem Himmel.
David Boder: Ja. In welchem Monat war das?
Jacob Minski: Das war im Monat Juli.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jacob Minski: Dann wurden wir in einen Raum hinein geführt, das saßen verschiedene Häftlinge mit Rasierklingen, die unseren ganzen Körper rasiert haben vollständig rasierten...
David Boder: Jüdische Häftlinge?
Jacob Minski: Teils jüdische, teils nichtjüdische.
David Boder: Haben sie Seife gebraucht?
Jacob Minski: Nein. Man hat nur rasiert mit trockenen Rasierklinge—auf trocken, trocken...
David Boder: Rasiermesser?
Jacob Minski: Rasierapparate. Keine Messer!
David Boder: Elektrische?
Jacob Minski: Nein, nein, nein, nein. Gewöhnliche Rasierapparate.
David Boder: Ja, die, hm, hm, Schadlosen.
Jacob Minski: Ja, ja, und war trocken—nicht mit Seife...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und zwar wurden diese Leute am ganzen Körper rasiert.
Jacob Minski: Wo überhaupt nur ein Härchen am Körper war...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Sie können sich vorstellen, wie schmerzhaft das ist, wenn man so à tempo rasiert wird und dann mit verschiedenen Tinkturen da eingeschmiert (lacht etwas).
David Boder: Warum?
Jacob Minski: Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich so aus Desinfektion.
David Boder: Desinfektion?
Jacob Minski: Brennen! Dann, hm, musste man unter eine Dusche...durchlaufen. Also jedenfalls verschiedene.
David Boder: Wie?
Jacob Minski: Also, ich meine , das ist so, hm,...unwesentlich die ganze Geschichte. Das Schlimmste war nur dieses, dieses Rasieren, das sehr unangenehm war. Dann warf man uns—nach Augenmass—Häftlingskleider zu.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Die Schuhe...
David Boder: Wurden Sie tätowiert?
Jacob Minski: Nein. Das...das, hm, werde ich Ihnen später begründen.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Wir...
David Boder: Die Schuhe...was war da?
Jacob Minski: Die Schuhe, die Schuhe konnte man behalten. Das heißt später wurde man sie auch los .
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . auf merkwürdige Weise. Wir...hm, nachdem wir so die ganze Nacht im Freien kampiert hatten...es war damals ziemlich kalt...
Jacob Minski: . . . wurden wir ins eigentliche Lager hinein geführt. Wir wurden dann in verschiedene Blocks...verschiedenen Blocks zugeteilt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das waren, hm,...ungefähr...so ähnlich wie Pferdeställe...wie so ein Pferdestall!
David Boder: Waren das alte Gebäude?
Jacob Minski: Das waren so...so Baracken, Baracken...
David Boder: Wurden diese speziell gebaut (unverständlich)?
Jacob Minski: Nein. Wir wurden in das Zigeunerlager...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . in das Zigeunerlager hinein geführt, das heißt vor uns waren Zigeuner drinnen, die man alle verbrannt hat.
David Boder: Wissen Sie etwas Näheres über die Zigeuner?
Jacob Minski: Nein, ich kann Ihnen...Ich weiß nur, dass man die Zigeuner durchweg, ich meine zum großen Teil, verbrannt hat. Sie wurden in dieses sogenannte Zigeunerlager hinein geführt. Und zwar einzelnen Blocks zu geteilt—kompliziert bis zu tausend (1000) Menschen, in einem Raum, wo normalerweise vielleicht drei hundert (300) Menschen Platz hätten.
David Boder: Ja. Haben Sie eine Idee, wenn und wer...wurden diese Blocks gebaut? Das ist Auschwitz wo Sie sprechen da...
Jacob Minski: Ich spreche von Birkenau.
David Boder: Birkenau?
Jacob Minski: Ja, Birkenau und Auchwitz, das ist alles das selbe.
David Boder: Ja, Birkenau und Auschwitz, das ist alles das selbe. Wo waren die Krematorien? In Birkenau oder Auschwitz?
Jacob Minski: Ich kann Ihnen das auch nicht...ich habe eigentlich nie darüber nach gedacht. Man ist ja nie zum Nachdenken gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Man war ja eigentlich wie einen Hammel Herde, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Ja, aber man hat doch die Krematorien gesehen, die Schornsteine gesehen...
Jacob Minski: Man hat sie rauchen gesehen, persönlich habe ich sie nicht gesehen, nur von Weitem...
David Boder: Haben Sie den Rauch gesehen?
Jacob Minski: Ja. Rauchen schon. Und zwar (beide sprechen).
David Boder: Und wie hat der Rauch ausgesehen?
Jacob Minski: Hm, ein dunkler Rauch.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Dunkel. Wir...also, wie gesagt, diese Blocks...für die, hm,...wir wurden so hinein gepfercht...
David Boder: Und wer hat diese Blocks gebaut? Wann wurden die gebaut?
Jacob Minski: Das kann ich Ihnen auch nicht sagen.
David Boder: Wurden die schon vorher gebaut oder waren sie speziell gebaut>
Jacob Minski: Das kann ich Ihnen auch nicht genau sagen. Das weiß ich auch nicht.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Jedenfalls der Block Älteste, der die Ansprache an uns hielt, das war ein Pole, kein Jude.
David Boder: Was hat er gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Er sagte, er wüßte von den Leuten...er wüßte...
David Boder: War er ein Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Es war ein Häftling, ja. Er wüßte von den Lodz...speziell von den Lodzer Juden, dass sie Gold und Brillanten bei sich hätten und dass sie es, hm,...dass sie es sogar, um es zu verstecken in der Lage...fähig wären, es herunter zu schlucken.
David Boder: Ja?
Jacob Minski: Sie sollten das freiwillig hergeben, sonst würde man, hm, uns...mit uns alles Mögliche machen und wir würden das später bereuen.
David Boder: Er hat das öffentlich gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Öffentlich vor uns—in unserem Block.
David Boder: War die Gestapo mit dabei?
Jacob Minski: Nein, nein, er hat das in unserem Block gesagt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Danach hat er...sagen wir mal, um uns eine Vorstellung zu geben was das heißt in einem Lager zu sein, nahm er Einen her und verprügelte ihn derart, so dass Einem hören und Sehen verging.
David Boder: Einen neuen Menschen?
Jacob Minski: Einen von uns.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Von uns.
David Boder: Und er war selbst ein Capo?
Jacob Minski: Er war...er war ein Block Ältester.
David Boder: Ja, aber ein Häftling.
Jacob Minski: Ein Häftling. Er war...
David Boder: Mit was hat er...womit hat er in verprügelt?
Jacob Minski: Mit einem dicken gro...Knüppel.
David Boder: Mit einem Stock?
Jacob Minski: Mit einem Stock...furchtbar.
David Boder: Und wo hat er hin gehauen?
Jacob Minski: Auf das Gesicht und auf den Rücken und überall, also so, dass er sich nicht mehr rühren konnte. Das machte dann natürlich einen furchtbaren Eindruck auf uns. Und er sagte darauf hin, jeder soll das, was er besitzt, auf den Boden...(Tonband überspringt einige Worte)...
David Boder: Also Sie sagten, er hat den Mann verprügelt und dann hat er was gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Er hat ihn furchtbar verprügelt und er hat...
David Boder: Aus was für einem Grund?
Jacob Minski: Ohne logischen Grund—nur um einen gewissen Eindruck auf uns zu machen, das heißt, das wir uns...zur...wenn irgend einer von uns noch etwas besäße, dass er es nachher dann abgäbe.
David Boder: . . . abgeben?
Jacob Minski: . . . abgeben. Das heißt, es solle (unverständlich) geschehen, er jagte uns auf die andere Seite rüber und die Leute konnten dann, was sie besaßen auf dem Platz liegen lassen.
David Boder: Ja, das war schon innen?
Jacob Minski: Ja, schon im Block...im Block
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Nachdem er festgestellt hatte, dass das was die Leute abgelegt hatten, zu wenig...
David Boder: . . . war...
Jacob Minski: . . . zu wenig war, gab er uns noch einmal einen Vortrag und sagte, wir würden gleich noch einmal auf den Platz rausgeführt werden und dort würde eine noch strengere Kontrolle vor sich gehen. Also eine Ermahnung noch einmal, falls wir etwas hätten...falls wir etwas hätten
David Boder: . . . das abzugeben
Jacob Minski: . . . das abzugeben
David Boder: Und wie könnten Leute es abgeben, die es verschluckt haben?
Jacob Minski: Na, das war ja natürlich eine lächerliche Bemerkung, der wollte uns irgendwie Angst einjagen
David Boder: Gab es Leute, die etwas Gold verschluckt hatten?
Jacob Minski: Nein, das ist ja, das sind ja lächerliche Ideen von dem Mann. Das hat er uns eingeredet, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Na, ich habe etwas von wem anderen gehört.
Jacob Minski: Also da ist mir nichts bekannt. Jedenfalls wurden wir dann zum Appellplatz gerufen und ich hatte damals noch verhältnismäßig anständige Schuhe an mir.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und ich sah, wie einer so um mich herum schwänzelte und meine Schuhe beäugte.
David Boder: Wer war das? Ein Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Auch ein Häftling.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Hm, er hieß mich meine Schuhe auszuziehen, um sie anzuprobieren. Sie passten ihm nicht recht, aber sie gefielen ihm zu sehr, als dass er sich davon trennen wollte und er schmiss mir ein paar alte Lumpen dafür.
Jacob Minski: Es wurde mir jedenfalls gesagt, nichts dem zu entgegnen, dass mir...da ist dann eine furchtbare Strafe dafür.
David Boder: Wer?
Jacob Minski: . . . und ich bestraft würde.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das Schlafen war das Schlimmste in einem solchen Block.
Jacob Minski: Auch die Ernährungswahl war (unverständlich—beide sprechen).
David Boder: Also bitte wollen Sie mal beschreiben. Wie haben Sie in so einem Block geschlafen?
Jacob Minski: Ich sagte Ihnen bereits, dass in einem solchen Block normalerweise drei hundert (300) Menschen hätten liegen können?
David Boder: Wo? Auf dem Fußboden?
Jacob Minski: Auf dem Fußboden. Natürlich auf dem Fußboden. Nachdem Fließen waren, wurde der Fußboden mit Brettern ausgelegt , jeden Abend wurden diese Bretter ausgelegt und am Morgen wurden sie eingesammelt diese Bretter und abends immer ausgelegt.
David Boder: Ja. Der Boden war Stein?
Jacob Minski: Der Boden war Stein.
David Boder: Stein, ja.
Jacob Minski: Also man hatte diesen Boden mit, mit, hm, den Brettern ausgelegt und man legte sich so lang; das heißt lang konnte man sich nicht legen, das war nicht möglich und man hat...es wurde ungefähr ausgemessen, wie viel Leute...sagen wir mal, zu viert...
David Boder: Waren da keine Pritschen, keine Betten?
Jacob Minski: Nein, so was gab es gar nicht, so was gab’s gar nicht bei uns .
David Boder: Nicht ein...
Jacob Minski: Es war nur der Fußboden da.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und zwar mussten wir in Hoppstellung
David Boder: Was ist Hoppstellung?
Jacob Minski: In Hoppstellung, das heißt, man setzte sich auf den Fußboden und die Beine muss man an sich...
David Boder: Heran ziehen...
Jacob Minski: anziehen, an die Brust heranziehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . so dass ungefähr auf jeder Seite fünf (5) Mann hinter einander saßen.
David Boder: Nicht Rücken zu Rücken, das heißt...
Jacob Minski: . . . die fünf zur Wand und die Anderen vor Einem.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jacob Minski: Jetzt können Sie sich vorstellen...
David Boder: So hat man geschlafen?
Jacob Minski: . . . in dieser...in dieser Hoppstellung sollte man nun die ganze Nacht verbringen. Das heißt bis morgens vier (4) Uhr.
David Boder: Ja, von welcher Uhrzeit abends? (beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: Das war natürlich...Von, hm,...wir gingen um sieben Uhr in den Block hinein
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Dann wurde die Ration verteilt, die Ration hing von der Güte des einzelnen Block Ältesten ab.
David Boder: Ja, was war die Ration?
Jacob Minski: Die Ration...die Ration bestand aus, hm, aus einem Stück Brot und einem Löffel, hm,...einem Löffel Fleisch, das heißt konserviertes Fleisch...
David Boder: Dosenfleisch...wie wurde das verteilt?
Jacob Minski: Ja,...es gab dann, man ging in so,...wie sagt man...der Reihe nach hinein in den Block und im Vorbeigehen, da hat man uns...da Eine mit dem Löffel, hm,...
David Boder: verteilt.
Jacob Minski: Ja, verteilt, auf das Stück Brot einen Löffel Fleisch, beziehungsweise einen Löffel Honig, was gerade zur Ration verteilt wurde.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Da die Block Ältesten gern Schnaps tranken...
Jacob Minski: . . . und es bestand auch ein gewisser Schwarzhandel im Lager...
David Boder: Zwischen wem?
Jacob Minski: . . . zwischen Häftlingen, die außerhalb des Lagers arbeiteten.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Es gab auch Häftlinge, die außer dem Lager...die außerhalb des Lagers arbeiten, also die irgendwelchen Kontakt hatten mit den Bauern...
Jacob Minski: . . . die brachten dann Schnaps in das Lager...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . wahrscheinlich...natürlich versteckt und...
Jacob Minski: . . . und dafür lieferten die Block Ältesten Brot.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ein Liter Schnaps ungefähr entsprach achtzig (80) Broten—achtzig (80) Kommiss-Broten oder Rationen...
David Boder: Ein Kommis-Brot war doch genug für einen Menschen
Jacob Minski: Ja, wir bekamen...offiziell bekamen wir so ein Kommiss-Brot für vier (4) beziehungsweise fünf (5) Leute...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Der Block Älteste gab, hm, teilte die Ration ein, so dass vielleicht zehn (10) oder fünfzehn (15) Leute dabei...
David Boder: Ja und dann hat er...behielt er den Rest?
Jacob Minski: .. . und den Rest behielte er, um sich dafür Schnaps zu verschaffen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Eine Reklamation gab es natürlich nicht, hm, wenn Sie es wagen würden zu reklamieren, weil Ihre Portion zu klein, hm,...
David Boder: War.
Jacob Minski: . . . sei, dann hat er sie furchtbar verprügelt, so dass sie...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: bewusstlos wurden.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Also man steckte das, was man bekam (lacht etwas), verglich unter einander die Portion, beziehungsweise man ging von Block zu Block und fragte: „Wieviel Brot hast Du heute bekommen?“ oder „wie sah...wie sieht Deine Portion aus?“ Jedenfalls das Schlafen, war, wie schon gesagt, furchtbar. Man konnte sich zwar, wenn es möglich war lang legen, nur lagen sie dann so wie die Heringe. Man konnte sich ja nicht bewegen. Nun stellen Sie sich vor, viele die blasenleidend waren...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . die nachts raus mussten, hatten...mussten entweder über den Kopf oder über den Fuß des, des, hm, Anderen gehen.
Jacob Minski: Noch dazu im Finsteren.
David Boder: Wie...wie war das? Man ist doch gesessen, sie waren...
Jacob Minski: Man konnte ja auch eventuell liegen, man hat das, man hat das untereinander ausgemacht...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . nicht wahr! Aber es war natürlich das Liegen, das war also, wie ich schon sagte, wie die Heringe—ohne, dass man sich überhaupt rühren konnte. Man durfte sich nicht bewegen da, das war natürlich unerträglich, man musste sich ja mal drehen...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: oder mal die Beine ausstrecken oder anziehen. Jetzt, wenn Einer raus ging und er musste dann über den Fuß des Andren gehen oder sonst wie über den Kopf treten, denn es war ja nicht so hell, dass man genau sehen konnte, dann fin..., dann fingen, fingen, fingen die Einzelnen an zu schreien. Der Block Älteste, der nebenan schlief, kam dann herein und machte „Sport“ mit uns. „Sport“ hieß in die Knie mit ausgestreckten Armen ungefähr eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde oder in Hoppstellung sitzen...
David Boder: In dieser...(unverständlich—beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: . . . in dieser Hoppstellung. Das war natürlich (unverständlich—Tonband überspringt) bei dem Block Ältesten.
David Boder: Wie hat der geschlafen, hat er ein Bett gehabt?
Jacob Minski: Ja, der hat ein Zimmerchen für sich gehabt mit so einer Couch, ein Diwan...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und Essen war für ihn nichts Außergewöhnliches, denn dieser hatte meistens Kontakt mit der Küche, da sie ja Geschäfte untereinander machten...
Jacob Minski: . . . und sie hatten von allem. Ein, ein Block Ältester war...war wie ein König.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Weil...(Tonband ist unverständlich)
Jacob Minski: Ich hatte eigentlich ein besonderes Glück, dass ich nach verhältnismäßig kurzer Zeit, aus Auschwitz wieder heraus kam.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Als man Fachleute suchte, es sollten nämlich Fachleute...
David Boder: Ein Moment.
David Boder: [In English] This ends spool seventy (70) of Mr. Minski and we are continuing on spool seventy one (71). Hm, August 23rd, 1946—an Illinois Institute of Technology Recording, Paris.
David Boder: Spool number seventy one (71) Mr. Minski continues, August 23rd, 1946 at the Headquarters of the American Joint Distribution Committee or the Immigration Division of the American Joint Distribution Committee. A recording of the Illinois Institute of Technology.
David Boder: [In German] Nun?
Jacob Minski: Wo soll ich da wieder zurück (flüstert—Rest unverständlich). Ja.
David Boder: Ja, also sie sprachen davon, dass der Capo herein kam und dann mit den Leuten „Sport“ machte.
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Dieses „Sport machen“, wie gesagt, geschah folgendermaßen: man musste in Hockstellung gehen, in die Knie mit ausgestreckten Armen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und in dieser Hockstellung musste man eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde verweilen.
Jacob Minski: Das war natürlich unerträglich.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und, hm, nach zehn (10) Minuten oder fünfzehn (15) Minuten, hm, sandte man jemand zu dem Block Ältesten mit der Bitte man möchte doch diese Strafe erlassen—man würde schon ruhig...
David Boder: Sein.
Jacob Minski: . . . ruhig sein.
David Boder: So er ist nicht einmal dabei gestanden?
Jacob Minski: Nein, er beauftragte irgendwelche Häftlinge aufzupassen und zwar...
David Boder: Und wie hat man gewusst, wenn eine halbe Stunde vorbei war?
Jacob Minski: Na mitunter hat man das im Freien gemacht, unter Aufsicht, wobei er ja auch auf und ab ging. Also, das war nicht zu umgehen.
David Boder: Aber ich fragte, wie hat man gewusst in der Nacht, dass eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde vergangen ist?
Jacob Minski: Na, jedenfalls die Zeit kam Einem (lacht etwas) furchtbar lange...
David Boder: Nun man hat die (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: . . . furchtbar lange vor. Wir...daraufhin waren wir wieder froh, wenn er diese Strafe erließ und man konnte in dieser furchtbaren Stellung wieder (lacht etwas) vor gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Morgens um vier (4) oder so gegen halb fünf ( ½ 5) wurde man aus diesem Block heraus gejagt und bekamen dann einen kalten Kaffee serviert,...
David Boder: Draußen?
Jacob Minski: . . . das war im Freien, da konnte es regnen oder gießen und man hatte natürlich keine Möglichkeit, es gab kein Dach,...der, der Raum da, dieser Stall da ausgeräumt werden musste.
David Boder: Und was hat man dazu (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
Jacob Minski: Zum Essen?
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das Geschirr das waren Blechteller; natürlich waren sie nie ausreichend für alle, sondern es musste immer ein Teil warten...
David Boder: Bis die Anderen fertig...
Jacob Minski: . . . bis die Anderen fertig waren.
David Boder: Konnte man das dann waschen dazwischen?
Jacob Minski: Man holte Wasser in Eimern und es wurde...natürlich außer einem Blechteller gab es nichts. Also es wurde alles mit den...dem Mund zugeführt...auf die primitivste Art und Weise. Sie haben versucht uns...
David Boder: Es gab keine Messer, Gabel?
Jacob Minski: Nein, das war ja...das war ja verboten. Wir haben versucht uns zuerst Holzstäbchen zu machen...
David Boder: Nehmen Sie Ihren Arm weg.
Jacob Minski: Wir haben versucht uns Holzstäbchen zu fabrizieren und mit diesen Holzstäbchen, hm, das Essen zu verzehren.
David Boder: (lacht etwas) Auf Chinesische Weise?
Jacob Minski: Auf chinesische Art, ja! (lacht)
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das wurde uns natürlich verboten und bei wem man diese Stäubchen erwischt hat, die nahm man ab.
Jacob Minski: Nun...hm, gearbeitet wurde nicht im Zigeunerlager...der größte Teil machte, hm,...keine, hm, war untätig, ja...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das war natürlich auch unerträglich. Man lief den ganzen Tag so hin und her, selbst eine Stecknadel hatte einen Wert und für eine Zigarette gab Einer seine Suppe her, die eigentlich das Leben bedeutete...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: . . . und ich, wie schon gesagt habe, hatte ich ein besonders Glück, dass ich nach, hm, verhältnismäßig kurzer Zeit wieder aus Auschwitz heraus kam. Ich hatte nie geglaubt, dass ich lebend aus diesem Lager heraus käme. Stellen Sie sich vor, soweit ich das beurteilen kann, war das, das größte Konzentrationslager in Europa—mit sechs und fünfzig (56) Quadratmeter gross. Also soweit das Auge überhaupt nur reicht sehen Sie nur Stacheldraht. Also sollte es ihnen gelingen, einen Stacheldraht zu überwinden—was ja kaum möglich ist...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . so hatten sie noch unzählige Stacheldrähte zu überwinden. Also war es praktisch ausgeschlossen.
Jacob Minski: Ich, hm,...es wurden eines Tages...wurden Fachleute gesucht...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und ein, hm, einer vom Arbeitsansatz, also auch ein älterer Häftling, prüfte dann die Leute nach ihrem Können...
Jacob Minski: Er war ein ganz besonders Strenger und war sehr gemein bei der Prüfung...
David Boder: Ein jüdischer Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Nein es war kein jüdischer Häftling, Er...
David Boder: Was war er?
Jacob Minski: . . . er war, hm, ich glaube irgendwie ein Pole, jedenfalls sprach er sehr gut deutsch und er prüfte die Leute nach ihrem...er hatte, ich muss sagen ein Allgemeinwissen von dieser...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . vom Arbeitseinsatz.
Jacob Minski: Also sollten...wurden Mechaniker gesucht, dann stellte er gewisse Fragen an sie und wenn sie nicht prompt auf diese Frage antworten konnte, dann hat er
David Boder: Gab er...
Jacob Minski: . . . gab er ihnen eine Ohrfeige (lacht)
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: (lacht)...weil er kein Mechaniker war. Natürlich die Leute, die—sagen wir mal—in der Nervosität nicht sofort eine Antwort geben konnte, obwohl sie vielleicht wirklich, hm, Fachleute waren...
Jacob Minski: . . . das erkannte er nicht an und er gab ihnen ein paar Ohrfeigen und dann wagten sie sich schon nicht mehr zu melden.
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Ahnung warum dieser Mann ein Häftling war?
Jacob Minski: Ich weiß nicht, was er, hm, was er gemacht hatte, jedenfalls trug er eine Armbinde „Arbeitseinsatz“...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und wurde dazu bestimmt Leute für Arbeiten einzuteilen...
Jacob Minski: . . . außerhalb des Lagers.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also eines Tages, als dann die Sachen mit den Transporten losgingen, das heißt man verschickte viele Menschen aus dem Konzentrationslager Auschwitz...
David Boder: Wohin?
Jacob Minski: Das wussten wir eben nicht, aber man konnte sich registrieren lassen...
David Boder: Für Arbeit?
Jacob Minski: . . . für Arbeit. Nur wusste man nicht wohin es geht. Es waren alle...ich ließ mich, zum Beispiel, an drei (3) verschiedenen Stellen eintragen. Man munkelte so was...wissen Sie, der Begriff „Transport“ hatte so was...war so ein bisschen anrüchig. Man glaubte, es ginge in den Ofen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und es kam auch vor, dass man sagte ein Transport ging weg zum arbeiten und er ging , hm, statt zum Arbeiten, ging er in den Ofen. Wir waren da alle sehr misstrauisch. Dann trugen wir uns an verschiedenen Stellen ein.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jacob Minski: Aus welchem Grund weiß ich selber nicht. Ich, hm,...mein Freund, der mit mir von Hamburg gekommen war, veranlasste mich, mich bei einer Gruppe von drei hundert (300)Fachleuten zu melden. Ich sollte mich bei einer Gruppe, hm,...es wurden drei hundert (300) Fachleute gesucht und zu dieser Gruppe meldete ich mich auch.
David Boder: In was für einem Fach arbeiten Sie?
Jacob Minski: Ich hatte überhaupt kein Fach. Ich hatte das, ich habe ihnen einfach gesagt, dass ich irgend ein Spezialist bin...(lacht)
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Es war ein älterer Herr da, der diese Leute aussuchte .
David Boder: Von außen? Ein Deutscher?
Jacob Minski: Von außen, ein Deutscher, in zivil.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und wir trugen ihm vor, was wir könnten und er entschied darauf hin, indem er, hm, und nach rechts oder nach links gehen ließ, die ausgesuchten Leute sollten eben nach rechts gehen.
David Boder: Ich sehe, Sie haben eine Brille. Haben Sie Ihre Brille auch im Lager getragen?
Jacob Minski: Nein, die hatte ich nicht. Leider hatte ich keine Brille im Lager, dadurch haben meine Augen sehr gelitten. Und ich habe hier schon meine Gläser ungefähr drei (3) Mal gewechselt und ich fürchte, dass ich sie zum vierten (4.) Mal wechseln muss, denn meine Augen sind sehr, sehr schwach.
David Boder: Ja, was tun Sie hier für Joint?
Jacob Minski: Ich bin hier im Filing Department.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Jacob Minski: Ich, hm, wie gesagt, ich meldete mich zu dieser Gruppe, glücklicherweise war der vom Arbeitseinsatz nicht zugegen und da ich diesen Mann in reinstem hochdeutsch ansprach hatte er mehr Vertrauen zu mir, als den Anderen, die ja meistens Polen waren.
David Boder: Ja und sprachen jiddisch.
Jacob Minski: Ja und sprachen jiddisch.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ich sagte ihm, dass ich bei der Firma Hochstrom und Kompanie gearbeitet hätte; das war eine große Firma für Hoch- und Tiefbau...
David Boder: War das wahr?
Jacob Minski: Ja, das war wahr. Ich habe nie dort gearbeitet. Ich habe das nur als Vorwand benutzt, um raus zu kommen.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: Wissen Sie, wenn man in so einem Lager ist, dann ist ein jedes Mittel recht und billig, um aus dieser Hölle raus zu kommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ich...mitunter hatte ich Gewissensbisse, weil ich achte, wenn man mich dann wirklich prüfen sollte und ich würde, hm, meine Prüfung nicht bestehen...
David Boder: Das waren nicht Gewissensbisse, sie hatten Angst.
Jacob Minski: Ja, ich meinte, ich hatte Tüsch...anfangs hatte ich keine Angst, nur dann hinterher, wie ich ausgesucht wurde.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also ich sagte dem Mann, dass ich bei der Firma Hochstrom und Kompanie gearbeitet habe und dieser Begriff Hochstrom und Kompanie genügte für diesen Mann, um ein gewisses Vertrauen, hm,...
David Boder: Zu haben.
Jacob Minski: . . . zu haben und er sagte nur: “Gehen Sie nach rechts!“ mit meinem Kollegen, der mich von Hamburg aus in sämtliche Lager begleitete. Also Einer dieser wenig Überlebenden mit denen ich von Anfang an zusammen war.
David Boder: Und was war Ihr Kollege?
Jacob Minski: Er war Klempner.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also für ihn war es schon wesentlich leichter, denn...
Jacob Minski: . . . ich war ja kein Handwerker.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Wir wurden also drei hundert (300) Leute ausgesucht und, hm, wir sollten uns...es sollte angeblich schon am nächsten Tag schon weiter gehen. Wir wurden also von Block zu Block in alle möglichen Blocks hinein gesteckt und im letzten Augenblick hat noch der Block Älteste uns das Brot unterschlagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also die ganze Aktion, weil er wusste wir werden am nächsten Tag abfahren, also konnte er für drei hundert (300) Leute die ganze Brot Portion einhalten. Ein Freund von mir, ein Zahnarzt, der jetzt in Lodz sich befindet, hatte den Mut unsere Portion zu reklamieren. Darauf hin hat er ihn furchtbar vermöbelt und er war froh, dass er...
David Boder: Sie meinen, er hat ihn furchtbar geschlagen?
Jacob Minski: Ja. Er glaubte im letzten Augenblick, da er ja fortgehen sollte, da hätte er noch...da hat er sich Mut gefasst und reklamierte die Portionen für uns alle.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Darauf hin hat in der Block Älteste ihn furchtbar vermöbelt und er kann eigentlich von Glück reden, dass ihm nichts Schlimmeres passiert ist. Wir wurden dann...wir bekamen dann eine Portion Brot, ungefähr zwei hundert fünfzig (250) Gramm und ein kleines Stückchen Wurst und wir fuhren dann in offenen Wagons...
David Boder: Welche Portion Brot bekamen Sie dann? Die vom Abend oder die Richtige?
Jacob Minski: Nein, nein, nein. Wir bekamen eine Portion Reisezehrung war das.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Unsere reguläre Ration hat er uns ja unterschlagen.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Die Ration, die Reisezehrung, die hatten wir schon nach ungefähr einer halben (½ ) Stunde verzehrt, denn wir hatten ja das Brot nicht vom Vorabend gehabt und weil wir hungrig waren.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: So fuhren wir für einen Tag. Die Wagons waren offen, zu beiden Seiten offen und eskortiert immer von 2 SS Leuten.
David Boder: Also die Türen der Wagons waren offen?
Jacob Minski: Die Türen, ja.
David Boder: Aber es waren Viehwagons?
Jacob Minski: Ja, Viehwagons, aber die offen waren.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also dadurch hatten wir ja die Möglichkeit Luft zu schnappen und, hm, für uns war das schon eine gewisse Beruhigung, dass wir, hm, schon unter , hm, dass wir fuhren. Dadurch wussten wir, dass wir nicht in den Ofen gehen.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Wir landeten in Görlitz...in Görlitz.
David Boder: Wo ist Görlitz?
Jacob Minski: Görlitz ist in Schlesien...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . in der Nähe von Breslau, ungefähr hundert (100) Kilometer von Breslau. Es ist ein, ein merkwürdiges Gefühl, wenn man...nach so langer Zeit wieder eine Zivilperson sieht. Wenn man in einem Konzentrationslager war, ich war schon acht und dreißig (38) in einem Konzentrationslager, und zwar in Oranienburg, anlässlich der Ermordung von Raat in Paris.
Jacob Minski: Da hat man doch alle...einen großen Teil der Juden eingefangen, ich meine, deren, hm, man habhaftig werden konnte und hat sie dann nach Oranienburg geschickt.
David Boder: Wo ist Oranienburg?
Jacob Minski: Oranienburg in der Nahe von Berlin, so ein paar Kilometer von Berlin.
David Boder: Ja. Und wann hat man Sie von Oranienburg befreit?
Jacob Minski: Dann wurde ich von Oranienburg befreit nach...ich war ungefähr zehn (10) Wochen in Oranienburg...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das Leben dort war auch gerade nicht so rosig, wie man sagen kann. Wir wurden...man wurde...dieses sogenannte“ Lagerreifmachen“...
Jacob Minski: . . . das besteht darin, bei Ankunft mussten wir 10 Stunden vor dem geladenen Stacheldraht stehen unbewegt, sich nicht rühren. Das war damals...hm, ich weiß nicht mehr welche Jahreszeit es war, jedenfalls es war unerträglich, unbewegt und der oben...es waren ja Posten, die da auf den Türmen, es waren solche Türme und, hm,...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und die Posten, die mussten natürlich aufpassen, was, hm,...
David Boder: Dass jeder steht. Und wie viele Stunden haben Sie gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Also wir standen damals vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden
David Boder: Das nannte man „Lagerreifmachen“?
Jacob Minski: „Lagerreifmachen“.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen zu essen gegeben?
Jacob Minski: Ja, später dann.
David Boder: Das war acht und dreißig (38)?
Jacob Minski: Ja. Dann wurden natürlich Verschiedene auf den Bock geschnallt, das heißt, wie so ein Turn...da ist wie so ein Turngerät...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . kennen Sie das?
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und man bekam dann so fünf und zwanzig (25) auf den Hintern...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . mit einem Ochsenziemer.
Jacob Minski: Das heißt...
David Boder: Mit einem Ochsenschwanz?
Jacob Minski: mit einem Ochsenschwanz, ja. Das war natürlich unerträglich...der Spanner natürlich, der haut den Hintern auf, das war besonders...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Ist Ihnen das auch passiert?
Jacob Minski: Nein. Mir ist es nicht passiert.
David Boder: Aber Sie haben es gesehen?
Jacob Minski: Ja, wir haben es gesehen. Beziehungsweise für Zigaretten rauchen bei der Arbeit...es gab natürlich manche Häftlinge, die unbedingt rauchen mussten.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das war natürlich das versteckt machen und wenn sie dabei erwischt wurden, dann bekamen sie drei, hm, eine Stunde oder zwei Stunden Pfahlhängen.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Jacob Minski: Das heißt, sie wurden auf einen Pfahl mit den Händen nach hinten...nach hinten gebunden;...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . gehängt, das heißt der Strang wurde hoch gezogen, so dass nur die Fußspitzen den Fußboden berührten.
Jacob Minski: So hing er in dieser Stellung...
David Boder: Aber die Fußspitzen konnten den Boden berühren.
Jacob Minski: Ja, aber nur die Fußspitzen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Sie können sich vorstellen nach zwei (2) Stunden, wenn man dann den...wenn man ihn dann los schnallte, dass er wie ein Sack dann zusammen sackt, nicht wahr. Aber das sind die ersten...
David Boder: Nun, Wie hoch waren die Hände?
Jacob Minski: Die Hände wurden ja so hochgezogen, also er schwebte ja in der Luft.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das ist natürlich ein furchtbarer Schmerz, ich meine von denen die das erzählt, die das selbst erlebt haben.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Damals in Oranienburg, es herrschte damals die furchtbarste...die furchtbarste Kälte soweit man sich erinnern konnte. Und ich arbeitete damals am Kanal und zwar mussten wir Loren...hm, Sand in Akkord schichten in so kleine Loren...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich meine Portion Brot, die ich in der Gesäßtasche meiner Häftlingskleidung hatte, wie Eis gefroren war. Sie können sich da vorstellen, wie kalt es war. Die Räder, die Räder drehten sich nicht mehr.
David Boder: Von der Lore.
Jacob Minski: . . . von der Lore. Wir waren vier (4) Mann an einer Lore, egal ob alt oder jung—mitunter die alten Leute, die konnte sich kaum halten und wir mussten sie noch mit schieben. Und der damalige Lagerführer Budahla, ein SS Mann, der Meisterboxer der SS, ein berüchtigter Kerl, er sprach wenig, aber wenn er eine Ohrfeige gab, da hatte man sich zwei (2) Mal überschlagen. So, ich erinnere mich nur, ich hatte damals,...ich musste mit einem Kollegen schwere Steine tragen und es war Glatteis. Und alles musste im Lauschritt geschehen. Und das ist natürlich unmöglich. Da erwischte er uns einmal, dass wir die Sachen im Gehen trugen und dann hat er uns so die Nummern...wir bekamen dann drei (3) Stunden vor dem geladenen Stacheldraht...wir mussten dann drei (3) Stunden stehen...
David Boder: Was heißt vor dem geladenen Stacheldraht? Man darf...es war...
Jacob Minski: Man konnte ihn doch nicht berühren, sonst war...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . er war ja mit zehn tausend (10000) Volt beladen.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: So musste man unbewegt stehen...nach Arbeits...also, das heißt, nach der Arbeit.
David Boder: Aber warum vor dem geladenen Stacheldraht?
Jacob Minski: Das war...ich weiß nicht...den Grund dafür.
David Boder: Ist jemandem was passiert, ist jemand gegen den...
Jacob Minski: Viele, viele sind natürlich an den gegangen, weil sie es einfach nicht mehr ertragen konnte.
David Boder: Oh, sie warfen sich an...?
Jacob Minski: Ja, sie warfen sich gegen den Stacheldraht. Und blieben natürlich dann kleben, es war...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: . . . und waren tot. Ich erinnere nur nachts...als wir nachts in Oranienburg ankamen, wir wurden von der SS getrieben und es war so eine Böschung und wir konnten nicht sehen, dass es plötzlich so abwärts ging. Und die Ersten kamen ins Stolpern...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . fielen um, Sie, Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn zwei tausend (2000) Leute hinterher kommen, konnten sie sich vielleicht nicht so schnell erheben, wir sind über sie hinweg, so dass wir gleich die ersten Toten mit ins Lager rein brachten.
Jacob Minski: (Hustet) das waren so kleine, unangenehme Erinnerungen...ja, mitunter muss ich, hm,...es gab auch humoristische Szenen...
David Boder: Ja, ich möchte das hören.
Jacob Minski: Wir mussten, zum Beispiel, hm,...wir waren zehn tausend (10000) Mann in Oranienburg zu meiner Zeit. Der Lager Älteste war ein damaliger Reichstag Abgeordneter und zwar wurde man...musste man immer ein Liedchen singen. Da stellte sich also Einer aufs Podium .und, hm...
David Boder: Wo? Während der Arbeit?
Jacob Minski: Nein, nein. Nach Arbeitsschluss, wenn alle ins Lager einkamen ..
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Da mussten wir...da wurde Appell gemacht...
Jacob Minski: . . . ob alles anwesend war. Wir mussten einmal zwölf (12) Stunden stehen, weil ein Mann abwesend war. Das heißt er hatte sich erhängt und man musste...man hat ihn suchen müssen.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: Und wir sollten noch...
David Boder: Und wo wurde er gefunden?
Jacob Minski: Oh, in irgend so einem Winkel hat er sich...
David Boder: Erhängt?
Jacob Minski: Erhängt. Und wenn nicht...man musste eben so lange stehen bis man ihn gefunden hat...und wenn wir vier und zwanzig (24) oder sechs und dreißig (36) Stunden gestanden sind, er musste gefunden werden.
David Boder: Und wie lange sind Sie gestanden?
Jacob Minski: Wir mussten damals,...einmal sind wir zwölf (12) Stunden gestanden.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Also es kam vor...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Aber musste man nicht zur Arbeit gehen?
Jacob Minski: In diesem Falle, das heißt, das kam drauf an.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Oh ja, nur an Weihnachten brauchten wir einen Tag nicht zu arbeiten, das heißt dafür wurde Sport gemacht, exerzieren.
David Boder: Was war das?
Jacob Minski: Wenn man geht links, rechts, links rechts...nicht wahr, nach militärischem Muster...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . meine Wenigkeit und noch Verschiedene, wir wollten uns davon drücken und täuschten vor, dass wir Fußschmerzen hätten. Daraufhin sagte einer von den Kolonnenführern: „Nun gut, wir werden dann langsam gehen“.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Plötzlich kam ein SS Mann auf uns zu und sagte „Was ist da los!“ (schreit) Daraufhin meldete der Militärische (unverständlich), dass er...„Diese Leute können nicht laufen.“ „Was sie können nicht laufen? „Laufen—hinlegen, laufen—hinlegen“ und so...
David Boder: Was soll das heißen?
Jacob Minski: Laufen—hinlegen, das heißt, zuerst laufen und sich dann ganz lang hinlegen.. Das war damals im Winter, im Schnee.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Er machte dann seinen „Sport“ mit uns.
David Boder: Das war?
Jacob Minski: Zuhören und (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: Das war damals im Lager in Oranienburg?
Jacob Minski: Ja, das war damals, ich erzähle nur kurze Episoden aus dem Lager dort...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ja. Also ich benützte dann eine Gelegenheit also eine Kolonne...
David Boder: Sie sagten, Sie wollten etwas Humoristisches erzählen .
Jacob Minski: Oh ja, ich bin da leider abgekommen (lacht) von dem Thema. Ich erzählte da von dem Singen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also es wurde dann einfach ein Thema angenommen, es...von mir aus: „Es saß ein Vöglein auf dem Baum“.
Jacob Minski: Jetzt fragen Sie,: „Kennen Sie das Lied?“
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jacob Minski: Wenn Sie mir zur Antwort geben: „Nein ich auch nicht, ich kenne es auch nicht“.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Mit solchen Dingen, ein Lied, das Sie nicht kennen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . war also ein SS Mann, der ging vorbei und sieht da, dass ich eigentlich stumm bin...ich beteilige mich nicht an dem Gesang...
Jacob Minski: Ja, dann fragt er eigentlich: „Warum singst Du nicht?“ Sagt er dann: „Ich kenne das Lied nicht.“ „Was Du kennst das Lied nicht?“ Und dann bekam ich eine auf die Schnauze und er sagte, „Dann sollst Du wenigstens die Schnauze aufreißen.“ Und abends wurde dann in unserem Block geübt, also wir mussten dann abends auch das Lied singen, auch wenn wir es nicht kennen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also, Sie sehen, die verlangen da einfach unmögliche Sachen, Sie sollen da ein Lied singen, das Sie nicht kennen. Natürlich für die...um noch auf eine andere Sache zurück zu kommen, da wir das Gelände nicht kannten...wir schon gesagt wurden wir dort eingeliefert und es gab schon, wir brachten schon die ersten Toten hinein. Wir mussten uns dann vor den geladenen Stacheldraht stellen und, hm, ein SS Mann ging so von Einem zum Andren und fragte, was man für einen Beruf hat. Daraufhin sagt einer, er ist Arzt, „Ja, dann hast Du ja unsere Frauen geschändet. Nicht wahr!“ und dann gab er ihm ein Paar links und rechts. Zu einem Anderen „Was bist Du?“ „Ein Rechtsanwalt.“ „Na ja, dann hast Du ja Viele von uns verknackst von uns, von unseren Leuten.“ Und er bekam auch ein paar, ein paar Ohrfeigen. Ich verstand nur Eines nicht, neben diesem Anwalt stand ein...stand ein Staatsanwalt. Wahrscheinlich hat ihn der...war er so verdreht, dass er ihm zur Antwort gab auf seine Frage,waser für einen Beruf hätte, dass er Staatsanwalt sei. Also, Sie können sich vorstellen, wie das auf so einen Mann wirkte, nicht wahr!
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Ein Staatsanwalt zu einer damaligen Zeit! Also er sagte ihm darauf hin: „Du wirst heute mit Katzenscheiße erschossen.“ Also, ich (unverständlich) ein bisschen,...und...ich weiß nicht was mit dem später geschehen ist. Jedenfalls machten sie mit Leuten, die stark beleibt waren, ihren...hatten sie eine besondere Freude. Die mussten Sport machen, das heißt sie mussten sich dauernd bücken und etwas aufhaben. Natürlich ein Mann, der einen starken Bauch hatte und speziell die Kleidung, die passte ja auch nicht immer, denn sie mussten sich die Häftlingskleidung dann mit einem Strick umwickeln, um die Hose festhalten zu können. Wir wussten natürlich nachts war es streng verboten aus dem Block herauszugehen, um austreten zu dürfen. Natürlich anfangs wusste man das nicht und wer das, hm, wer aus dem Block raus ging, hm, wurde natürlich sofort niedergeknallt , denn die...
David Boder: In Oranienburg?
Jacob Minski: In Oranienburg war das damals, denn die Leuchtkegeln, nicht wahr, und die Maschinengewehre...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: . . . die leuchteten jeden Block ab und sobald nur irgendwie sich Einer auf dem Hof so bewegte, wurde er sofort niedergeknallt. Auch geschah es in Fällen, dass die Postenkette, das heißt die, hm,...die uns bewachte, einfach die Häftlinge heran lotste und ihm sagte: „Komm mal her!“
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Es wurde uns gesagt, dass es streng verboten sei, die Postenkette zu überschreiten, da dann die Postenkette sofort schießen darf.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: Viele Häftlinge in Unkenntnis dieser , hm,...
David Boder: Regel.
Jacob Minski: . . . Regel, gingen ahnungslos auf sie zu und sie wurden natürlich...
David Boder: Erschossen.
Jacob Minski: . . . erschossen. (räuspert sich) Ja, ich erzählte Ihnen noch von, hm,...
David Boder: Also Sie kamen dann von Auschwitz, wohin?
Jacob Minski: Nach Görlitz.
David Boder: Alright.
Jacob Minski: Ich meine von Görlitz...in Görlitz, das war ein Arbeitslager. Natürlich im Vergleich zu Auschwitz—ein Paradies.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das Arbeitslager—es war eine Munitionsfabrik. Wir mussten in einer Munitionsfabrik arbeiten als Häftlinge—immer eskortiert von der SS. Und abends wurden wir ins das Lager rein gebracht.
David Boder: So—die Fabrik war außerhalb des Lagers?
Jacob Minski: Die Fabrik war außerhalb des Lagers.
David Boder: Und Sie sagten, Sie haben zum ersten Mal andere Menschen gesehen.
Jacob Minski: Ja, ja. Das war natürlich...das wirkte auf uns...das machte natürlich auf uns einen ganz besonderen Eindruck, vor allem weil wir ja auch mit Zivilleuten arbeiteten. Es war natürlich verboten sich mit ihnen zu unterhalten, jedoch in und wieder wechselte man, hm, mit ihnen...
David Boder: Ein Wort?
Jacob Minski: . . . ein Wort. Und da auch dort Franzosen und alle möglichen Nationalitäten dort arbeiteten, so hatte man Gelegenheit hin und wieder ein Brot zu bekommen oder im Tauschwege für Zigaretten sich etwas sonderproviantlich zu beschaffen. Aber das erscheint sehr weniger interessant, als vielleicht...hm, gewisse Verhältnisse im Ghettoleben.
David Boder: Wo?
Jacob Minski: Ich meine, um auf Lodz noch einmal zurück zu kommen...
David Boder: Sie wollen auf Lodz zurück kommen...
Jacob Minski: Ich denke speziell an den furchtbaren Hunger. Der Hunger, der war so gross, dass wir verfaulte Kartoffelschalen damals, hm,...sie mit Sacharin zu, hm, irgend einem, hm, Brei zu verarbeiteten. Also eine Masse nur den Magen zu stopfen. Und zwar dazu trank man einen Liter Kaffee, teils machten wir aus Kaffeesatz mit Sacharin, hm, irgendwelche –hm es nannte sich Koteletts, nicht wahr,...auf der Pfanne trocken, weil wir ja aus Kaffee Grund...
David Boder: Oh, etwas aus Kaffee Grund?
Jacob Minski: . . . ja aus Kaffee Grund, aus Kaffee Grund mit Sacharin. Das Leben war natürlich wahnsinnig teuer. Wir bekamen ein Brot für eine Woche.
David Boder: Ein Brot?
Jacob Minski: Ja, ein ganzes Brot, das heißt man musste sich das selber einteilen,...die Ration. Sie bekamen ein Brot von zwei (2) Kilo, mitunter ist es nicht ganz zwei (2) Kilo. Wir...man bat...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Also, man bat...man bat um ein Spezielles,...(lacht etwas)...genau das Gegenteil was heute ist. Man hat recht altes Brot, damit, man nicht, hm,...so viel essen wird.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also ich teilte es mir immer so ein...so ungefähr für jeden Tag zwei (2) Schnitten...
Jacob Minski: Dann hin und wieder nahm ich (lacht etwas) eine Anleihe, so dass ich die letzten drei Tage kein Brot mehr hatte. Die Preise spielten...es war eine Zeitlang so, dass Sachwerte überhaupt nichts...keinen besonderen Wert hatten, während Lebensmittel eine unglaubliche, hmmmm,...hm,...
David Boder: Teuer waren?
Jacob Minski: . . . einen unglaublichen Wert hatten. Ich erinnere mich nur, ich hatte...einen neuen Anzug da bei mir; einen neuen Anzug der mich, der mich in Hamburg drei hundert fünfzig (350) Mark kostete. Es war schon ein gewisses Vermögen. Ich bekam dafür ein Kilo Mehl.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jacob Minski: Ein...ein paar Schuhe konnten Sie für hundert (100) Gramm Margarine erstehen, also Sie sehen schon aus diesen Preisen, dass, hm, die Sachen nichts wert waren und sie konnten die Deutschen, die mitunter mit einem Brot und mit einem Pfund Margarine ins Ghetto rein kamen, gingen dann mit einem Koffer voll neuer Sachen heraus. Denn um das Leben zu retten , war man bereit alle diese Sachen zu opfern. Ich war auch schon eine Zeitlang so...der Hunger hat mich so weit herunter gebracht, dass ich kaum meinen Dienst versehen konnte. Ich wurde...zwei Mal, ich erinnere mich, zwei Mal inohnmächtigem Zustand nach Hause gebracht...
David Boder: Als Feuerwehrmann in Lodz?
Jacob Minski: . . . als Feuerwehrmann, weil ich einfach zu schwach war. Ich, hm,...als ich mich in dem Spiegel ansah, sah ich schon den Tod vor Augen. Ich erinnere mich, wir waren anfangs ein hundert sechzig tausend (160000) Juden und wir gingen dann bis auf vierzig tausend (40000).
David Boder: Nun ja, viele wurden ja weg geschickt!
Jacob Minski: Viele wurden weg geschickt, aber ein großer Teil, hm, ist...an Typhus gestorben. Die...
David Boder: Haben Sie dort einen Doktor—Doktor Falk in Lodz gekannt?
Jacob Minski: Es ist möglich, sehen Sie, ich kannte ein...(unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: Sie können sich nicht erinnern?
Jacob Minski: . . . aber ich kann mich nicht definitiv erinnern. Vor allen Dingen die Wohnverhältnisse waren furchtbar. Es war...man hatte für das Lodzer Ghetto das schlimmste, den schlimmsten Teil, hm, von Lodz ausgewählt, also wo nur das größte Gesindel gelebt hat . Es waren meistens so eingefallene Häuser in den furchtbar...unter den furchtbarsten Verhältnissen lebten die Leute—mitunter zehn (10) Familien—in einer, in einer Wohnung. Sie können sich vorstellen unter den furchtbarsten hygienischen Verhältnissen was, hm, dabei heraus kam.
David Boder: Konnten Sie...
Jacob Minski: Also, wenn man zum Beispiel, etwas benötigte...es war natürlich schwer oftmals, sagen wir mal Medikamente, im sogenannten Schleichhandel zu erstehen.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Der Preis war natürlich unerschwinglich. Ich, als Feuerwehrmann verdiente ich drei (3) Mark, drei (3) Ghetto Mark...
David Boder: Täglich?
Jacob Minski: Drei (3) Ghetto Mark täglich.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ein Brot kostete im Schwarzhandel ein tausend acht hundert (1800) Mark. Sie können sich ungefähr vorstellen, wieviel Brot ich mir dafür kaufen konnte. Brot, die Suppe, die Wassersuppe, die man bekam, entsprach dem Dollar Kurs. Kamen viel Kartoffel rein, schickten die Deutschen viel Kartoffel rein, sank die Suppe, sagen wir mal, von fünfzig (50) Mark—sie erreichte mitunter einen Stand von fünfzig (50) Mark...
Jacob Minski: . . . hm, bis den Tiefstand vom zwei fünfzig (2.50).
David Boder: Aber Sie mussten doch etwas umsonst bekommen, nicht wahr?
Jacob Minski: Ja, die bekam ich ja umsonst. Aber, sagen wir mal, es hatte Einer Durchfall oder sonst was...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und er konnte die Suppe nicht essen, verkaufte er sie.
Jacob Minski: . . . vor der Küche standen dann immer so Aufkäufer, die die Zettel, die Suppenzettel aufkauften...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . für einen gewissen Preis und sie an einen Anderen, an einen Hungrigen dann...
Jacob Minski: . . . sagen wir er hatte ein Stück Brot verkauft. Es gab manche, die hatten einen merkwürdigen Standpunkt. Sie verkauften ein Brot für ein tausend acht hundert (19800) Mark—ihr eigenes Brot...
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: . . . und kauften sich lieber dafür Suppen, um sich den Bauch voll zu pumpen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Das war natürlich vom...
Jacob Minski: . . . vom gesundheitlichen Standpunkt vollkommen falsch. (räuspert sich) Wenn sie etwas kaufen wollten, das einen Wert von zwei hundert (200) oder drei hundert (300) Mark präsentierte, dann verkauften sie ein Stück Brot. Er wog das dann ab...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: ....so als ob er Gold wiegen würde und, hm, sie beglichen dann die Rechnung mit Brot.
David Boder: Beantworten Sie mir eine Frage.
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: Können Sie mir irgend etwas über...können Sie mir etwas über das Geschlechtsleben erzählen von dieser Zeit in Lodz und nachher im Lager?
Jacob Minski: (seufzt) Ja, auch das war natürlich ein ungesunder Zustand, da Männlein und Weiblein zusammen hausten...verstehen Sie, ich möchte fast sagen, die Leute schämten sich schon gar nicht.
David Boder: Ja. Sagen wir, wenn eine Familie zusammen war,
Jacob Minski: Ja?
David Boder: . . . wie haben die den Geschlechtsakt vollzogen?
Jacob Minski: Ganz—ich möchte fast sagen- ungeniert. Diese Leute, ich erinnere mich, die haben...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Ich erinnere mich, wir haben uns—eine gewisse Gruppe als wir von Hamburg kamen—einfach irgendwo einquartiert. Wir waren ungefähr acht (8) Leute, darunter auch eine Frau. Und sie genierte sich gar nicht, sie zog sich ganz nackt aus, um sich zu waschen. Also die Leute...waren mit der Zeit...also das Lagerleben machte die Leute natürlich...da wird man gefühllos gemacht.
Jacob Minski: . . . vollkommen gefühllos. Man empfand nichts mehr. Sagen wir, wenn man in der Nacht...
David Boder: Ohne Geschlechtsgefühl?
Jacob Minski: Ohne jegliches Geschlechtsgefühl. Wenn der Hunger...Sie dürfen nicht vergessen, wenn der Hunger so gross ist, dann denkt man darüber nicht nach. Ich glaube eher, dass Einer, der satt ist, eher solche Gedanken haben könnte, als Einer der hungert. Das kommt davon—der Magen muss gefüllt werden.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Also daher auch verständlich...
David Boder: So das war kein Problem?
Jacob Minski: Bei mir, verstehen Sie, das war kein Problem, es war wirklich kein Problem. Wie die Leute...vielleicht...wenn Einer natürlich in einer Brot Fabrik gearbeitet hat, der konnte sich immer so ein Stück Brot, hm,...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und Sie wissen ja, mit einem Stück Brot...das war ein Kapital.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Minski: Mit einem Stück Brot, da konnte man alles Mögliche kaufen. Ich weiß anfangs, als ich ins Ghetto kam...
David Boder: Können wir zu der Geschlechtsfrage zurück...
Jacob Minski: . . . da war diese Prostitution so stark...auf der Strasse zum Beispiel, mehrere die preisten sich an für ein Stück Brot, für eine Scheibe Brot.
David Boder: Ja, jüdische Mädel?
Jacob Minski: Jüdische Mädels, natürlich, wir waren im Ghetto.
David Boder: Wo haben sie dann gegeben?
Jacob Minski: Sie gingen in einen Hof rein oder irgendwo, wahrscheinlich hat die Mutter gearbeitet, dann hat die Tochter dann die Gelegenheit, hm,...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . gehabt.
Jacob Minski: Natürlich das war, das kam ihnen dann später zum Verhängnis, denn diese Mädels, die da nicht gearbeitet hatten, wurden dann weg geschickt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Wer nicht registriert war...
David Boder: Als Arbeiter?
Jacob Minski: Man musste registriert sein in irgend einem Betrieb. Wer nicht registriert war als Arbeitsloser...jeder Arbeitsloser oder Leute, sagen wir mal, die nur irgend ein kleines Vergehen sich zu Schulden haben kommen lassen, die wurden auch ausgesiedelt.
David Boder: Nun wollen wir wieder zurück kommen. Sagen wir der Block Älteste in dem Lager...
Jacob Minski: Ja.
David Boder: . . . der genug zu essen hat...
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Idee, wie er seine geschlechtlichen Bedürfnisse befriedigt hat?
Jacob Minski: Darüber, muss ich ehrlich sagen, habe ich (lacht)...habe ich mir keine Kopfschmerzen gemacht, denn man hatte so viel Sorgen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . dass man sich...dass man, hm, weniger darüber nachgedacht hat als man...
David Boder: Nun...ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . man wusste zwar...Später habe ich an dem Gerle, zum Beispiel, erfahren, dass viel Block Älteste so Jünglinge, hm,...
David Boder: Jünglinge hatten.
Jacob Minski: . . . Jünglinge hatten, nicht wahr, mit denen sie sich dann amüsierten. Ich weiß...so Kinder von zehn (10) bis zwölf (12) Jahr.
David Boder: Und was für Kinder waren das?
Jacob Minski: Sie hatten...die Meisten...es waren so...auch Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Sie sollten eigentlich zur Arbeit gehen, aber sie fanden immer einen Grund sie im Lager zurück zu behalten. Ein Block Älteste kann das ja machen.
David Boder: Und?
Jacob Minski: Er wurde als krank registriert und dann...
David Boder: Dann hat ihn der Block Älteste behalten.
Jacob Minski: . . . dann hat ihn der Block Älteste behalten.
David Boder: Nun. Also kommen wir zu der allgemeinen Situation im Lodzer Ghetto zurück.
Jacob Minski: Das Ghetto von Lodz...
David Boder: Oder wollen wir so sagen: wo wurden Sie befreit?
Jacob Minski: Ja, befreit wurde ich indirekt von den Russen, denn ich habe eigentlich schon früher, einen Tag früher das Lager verlassen. Es war schon...
David Boder: Wo war das?
Jacob Minski: In Görlitz...
David Boder: Görlitz, wo war das?
Jacob Minski: Das war schon...das ist in Schlesien. Ich sagte schon ungefähr hundert (100) Kilometer von Breslau.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Die Russen waren schon wochenlang ungefähr elf (11) Kilometer von Görlitz.
Jacob Minski: Und merkwürdiger Weise sind sie nie vor gegangen. Sie blieben dort ungefähr—ich glaube—zehn (10) Wochen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und man wusste nie...ich erinnere mich nur, von der Fabrik die Leute, die sind oft in Autos ganz nah an die Grenze, wo die Russen waren, um, um Materialien zu holen. Es war mir so unverständlich, wie die das machen konnten.
David Boder: Das war eine Art von Sitzkrieg.
Jacob Minski: Ja, eine Form von Sitzkrieg, sie sind nicht weiter gegangen. Aber man hatte schon gewisse Vorbereitungen getroffen. Wir waren schon zwei (2) Mal auf der Flucht von den Russen; das heißt, wir...es ist ein Befehl an uns ergangen, an das Lager—das Lager zu räumen, weil man ja befürchtete, dass eines Tages die Russen einmarschieren würden. Also man wollte keine Beweise gegen sie haben.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Wir befanden uns unterwegs und leider wurden sehr viele von unseren Häftlingen niedergeschossen, speziell von der ukrainischen SS, die kaum ein Wort deutsch sprach...
David Boder: Warum?
Jacob Minski: . . . weil sie nicht gehen konnten. Alles was nicht gehen konnte wurde entweder unterwegs niedergeschossen beziehungsweise auf einen Wagen geladen und unterwegs in einem Wald wurden dann Gräben ausge..., hm, ausgeschachtet. Und ich erinnere mich, ich wurde einem Kommando zugeteilt zum Ausgraben, das heißt um aus zu schachten, um Gräber aus zu schachten.
David Boder: Was heißt das?
Jacob Minski: . . . ein Kommande von fünfzig (50) Leuten, die Gräber machen, um die Toten unterwegs...
David Boder: zu verscharren.
Jacob Minski: zu verscharren. Da passierte Folgendes: diese Häftlinge, die nicht marschieren konnten—man konnte sie ja nicht...man wollte sie ja nicht auf der Strasse einfach so erschossen da liegen lassen. Die hatte man dann auf einen Wagen geladen und zusammen mit den Toten hat man sie dann in den nächsten besten Wald, hm, erschossen und dann dazu genommen. Das heißt ich erinnere mich an einen SS Mann. Er war vier und zwanzig (24) Jahre alt und machte den Eindruck eines unschuldigen (lacht etwas)...
David Boder: Jünglings...
Jacob Minski: Jünglings, als ob er nicht bis drei (3) zählen konnte und der war der Meisterschütze. Jeden Tag hat er ungefähr so dreißig (30) bis vierzig (40) niedergeschossen—hat selbst mit geholfen das Grab schaufeln...
David Boder: Ja und warum?
Jacob Minski: . . . wahrscheinlich für ihn war das...ein gewisser Sport. Dann ließ er die Toten rein legen, zählte ungefähr ab, für wieviel er noch Platz hätte .
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: Und dann ließ er diese unschuldigen, diese ahnungslosen Menschen vom Wagen runter gehen, Indem er noch sagte: „(unverständlich)“ dieser ukrainische Ausdruck. Dann mussten sie sich hinlegen und er knallte sie dann mit dem Karabiner indem er seinen Fuß...seinen, seinen Fuß auf den Kopf des, hm, des Betroffenen nieder legte. Und so musste Einer nach dem Anderen zusehen, wie er...
David Boder: War das ein Ukrainer?
Jacob Minski: Das war ein, ein ukrainischer SS. Ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun.
Jacob Minski: Es war Einer dieser, im letzten Augenblick wurden sie dann weg geschickt, wahrscheinlich aus Angst, dass sie in die Hände der Russen fallen könnten. Die ganze ukrainische SS, die uns zugeteilt war, wurde weg geschickt. Das waren Furchtbare, die waren die Schlimmsten.
David Boder: Nun also, sagen Sie mir das, hm, also wo wurden Sie befreit im Krieg?
Jacob Minski: Oh ja. Jetzt war es so, ein Tag bevor—das war am siebten (7.) August...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und die Russen sind ungefähr am achten (8.) August einmarschiert, am achte (8.) oder neunten (9.) sind wir aus dem Lager raus, wir konnten schon machen, was wir wollten. Na, es war schon ein (unverständlich) nachdem der Lager...nachdem der Lagerführer uns erklärt hatte, wir wären...wir waren praktisch gesehen—wir wären frei. Wir könnten im Block bleiben...im Lager bleiben.
David Boder: War der Lagerführer ein Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Nein, der Lagerführer war ein SS...
David Boder: Und er ist nicht weg gelaufen?
Jacob Minski: Er ist...ich muss eigentlich sagen, er hat sich ausnahmsweise, was man sonst sagt, verhältnismäßig anständig benommen, das heißt ich habe nie gesehen, dass er einen Häftling angerührt hat. Viel schlimmer war der Lager Älteste—das war ein Oberbandit.
David Boder: War der ein Häftling?
Jacob Minski: Der war ein Häftling, ein...aber er war kein jüdischer Häftling.
David Boder: Also was hat dieser SS Mann gesagt?
Jacob Minski: Er hat gesagt, dass wir wirklich frei wären. Wenn wir wollten könnten wir zu den Amerikanern rüber gehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Minski: . . . und wer bei den Russen bleiben will, der könnte, der sollte im Lager bleiben. Und von...
David Boder: Aber er hat gesagt, dass der Platz geräumt wird?
Jacob Minski: Ja, das heißt, nachdem da gingen wir schon, denn da war schon so ein Durcheinander, dass jeder eigentlich machte, was er wollte.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Minski: Es war...das Militär wurde abgezogen und unterwegs...ich war noch mit verschiedenen Kollegen, da haben wir so die ganze Tschechoslowakei durchquert...
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind weg gegangen?
Jacob Minski: Wir sind weg, ja, und zwar in einem SS Wagen, hm, mit, hm,...
David Boder: In einem SS Auto?
Jacob Minski: Nein, nein, nein, (lacht etwas) mit Pferd und Wagen. Wir haben es genommen, der war noch voll mit Proviant und mit allem Möglichen SS Stiefeln und alles Mögliche. Da haben wir so die ganze Tschechoslowakei durchquert bis wir nach, hm, hm, Wien kamen...
David Boder: Niemand hat sie abgestoppt, niemand? (lacht etwas)
Jacob Minski: . . . wir sind auf dem Weg natürlich schon Russen begegnet, nicht wahr. Aber sie sahen ja, dass sie es mit Häftlingen zu tun hatten, also...sie haben uns immer vorbei fahren lassen. Hm, wir kamen dann bis Wien, kamen in Wien an. Da heißt unterwegs wurden wir natürlich von der Bevölkerung sehr gut aufgenommen. Und Sie können sich vorstellen—in dem Augenblick die Freiheit zu geniessen, nachdem wir ja niemals dran geglaubt haben, dass wir davon weg zu kommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Minski: Wir kamen dann, wie schon gesagt bis Wien an und in Wien durften wir nicht verbleiben.